December is no any pigment view in terms
of the bitters but also of course your
fans are waiting for your part in The
Hobbit now tell me how do you get ready
for those battle scenes and all he got
some singing in there as well haven't
you well in the hob yeah I mean there's
the process is pretty long on the hobbit
you know he got up in the morning or in
their prosthetics and makeup from
caution for about three hours but uh but
to get ready for battle scenes we were
there for two or three months before we
started shooting we did a hugely
vigorous kind of training regime we but
it was great it was just like being
offered the opportunity to kind of be a
teenager like play you know he went
horse riding heated stunt training we
did dwarf movement we did music and
movement the whole thing was great so
I'm not hugely enjoyable what effects
have I knew working in 3d and also with
the 48 frames per second as well well
from my point of view doesn't make any
difference at all because you know
acting is acting I mean I've seen the 48
films now I think you know Peters
someone is always trying to kind of like
cross boundaries I don't think he
doesn't you know certainly doesn't do a
kind of robot nurse or a Fae does
because he thinks that's the next stage
and I think that in a few years time
we'll be watching 48 a lot of course
people have the option of 48 of 24 I
loved the four th I thought I made a
very immediate I know some people have
different views but he's a great
storyteller he's a great man he's a very
down-to-earth guy he's quite poverty
himself today the truth but he's um he
certainly touched Virginia's all right
and what do you make of Martinez and
bilbo baggins Martin's sensation he's
absolutely sensational you know I think
to carry the weight of that rule they
aren't the expectation of our film that
they thought was unmei cabal and then to
play that rule and he was just
incredibly generous very very funny guy
and hugely talented he's um yeah he
might it might be all right from cell
phone
you